- Hello!
- [Marcus] Hello!
- First of all, have you met Hughie?
I didn't know if y'all--
- We just met.
I was telling him, my
parents are huge fans
of both of you guys.
- [Kelly] Yeah, well,
they have great taste.
- Yeah.
Fantastic taste.
My mom was sad she could not be here.
She's workin'.
- [Kelly] Make sure you rub it in.
- I will.
- I'm just kidding.
(laughing)
- I'ma take a ton of
pictures, don't worry.
- It was such a party without you.
Would you like some ice cream?
- [Marcus] I would.
- If you would, you can grab it anytime.
- [Marcus] Has anybody, like,
ever turned down ice cream?
- [Kelly] Not me.
- No, I've talked to
my friends about this.
I feel like ice cream is, like,
one of those things that everybody
has a flavor that they like.
- Like it's the only thing--
- Like pizza.
- Exactly, like pizza!
Nobody doesn't like it.
- Yeah.
And if you don't, you're weird.
- [Marcus] Yeah, you're weird!
- But I wish I were you.
But I hear you just started driving.
- I did.
- You're 20, man!
- I'm 20.
I was late to the train.
So I got my license when I was,
or, to the car.
I got my license when I was--
(laughing)
I got my license when I
was like 18 years old.
I had to film this movie,
and so I was forced to get my license
so I could drive a pick-up
truck in one of these scenes,
and then eventually, I
was kinda scared to drive.
I was like, I have Uber.
I can get anywhere I need.
Like, it's nicer to be
chauffeured, you know what I mean?
Fall asleep.
I'm a busy man.
- I'm a (laughs).
(audience applause)
- But then, eventually, overcame the fear,
and now I've been driving for four months.
(audience cheers)
- I so don't get your generation.
Like, as soon as I could get a license,
I was like, freedom!
It was like "Braveheart."
- I know, now I feel the freedom,
but like, I feel like the
Ubers were just so convenient.
I fall asleep.
I'm like, who's gonna kidnap me?
I'm, like...
- You are so trusting.
So many!
Have you heard of "Dateline"?
- Actually, my dad is
a huge "Dateline" fan,
so I used to watch those all the time.
- I had to stop
because I was terrified
in my house all the time.
So literally, I used to always watch it,
and then my husband was just like,
"This is gettin' weird."
Yeah, I got really,
were you into cars growing up?
Both of y'all?
- Yes.
My grandfather actually
owns an auto body shop.
I'm gonna plug him real quick.
A Action Auto.
- [Kelly] Eh!
There he is!
(audience applause)
But if you need some body work done,
I can't promise he won't sell you a lemon,
but don't tell him I said that.
But when I was younger,
I used to work there,
and he would pay me like $50
to work the entire summer.
- [Kelly] The entire summer?
- The entire summer, so child labor laws,
people need to get on that.
Somebody, come after him.
(laughing)
But my sister would work the phones,
and she would just get
to sit in the office
and sit in air conditioning
and just wait for the phone to ring,
and she'd get paid $100
for the whole summer.
I was sweeping the yard,
cleaning all of the cars,
like, there was some inequity there.
It was like, clear favorites.
(Kelly laughing)
It was kind of reverse gender roles
when it comes to the wages right there.
- You were like,
I'm speaking for the men!
- Yeah, exactly.
Stand up!
- Are you a big car guy?
- Well, actually, I live in Montana,
so I'm more of a horse guy.
- I love horses!
That's amazing!
(audience cheers)
You just brought the sexy cowboy in!
I like it!
- That's a lot cooler.
- I know, my husband rides horses.
I did, I liked riding horses
until I bent my tailbone,
and then I was like, you know what?
I'm out.
I'm not Annie Oakely.
Yeah.
I was like, that hurts.
Forever.
Yay!
But you actually got your start
in the business very young,
so what was your first job,
other than sweeping your family's yard?
- Oh boy, take me back.
No, I'm joking, it was like 10 years ago.
But I guess that is a while ago.
I started acting when I was 10 years old.
I booked a little show called "Castle."
I heard that you're a fan.
- I'm a huge fan,
and I actually remember this.
- [Marcus] You have a picture!
- [Kelly] I know!
- Oh, god.
- It was such a great show!
- Yeah, it was so good,
but my character's name,
I had a one-episode guest star role.
I was so proud of it.
I ran in, one of the characters,
I ran up to him.
My name was Timmy in the show.
Of course, a little kid named Timmy.
Shocker.
- He's in the well!
- Timmy's in the well!
But I ran up to him,
and I was like, Uncle Javi,
you wanna see my baseball cards?
- [Kelly] And that was your moment.
- That was my big moment.
So that was the break.
That was it.
(audience cheers)
- First of all, you are hilarious!
You are so fun!
- [Marcus] Thank you.
- I mean, you're like a walking party.
So you're on "Blackish."
So who's the most surprising
fan that you've met?
- The most surprising fan I've met, huh...
What about that?
Okay, so, let me start by saying this.
We got to go to the White House
for the Easter Egg Roll
a couple years back.
Okay, I know you guys can
see where this is going.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- It's pretty good from here.
But we got to go to the White
House for the Easter Egg Roll.
Got to bring my entire family.
Went to the Oval Office bathroom.
Their paper towels are
literally like real towels.
- I love that you went to the bathroom.
- No, the bathroom was the coolest part!
It was like, marble all over the place.
I was like, whoa--
- Most people are like,
fascinated by the office.
- Yeah, no, but the bathroom was tight!
Okay?
We spend a lot of time in the bathroom.
(audience applause)
But, yeah, we got to meet
Michelle and Barack Obama.
It was an amazing experience.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, there it is.
If you pay close attention,
you can see my arm isn't around Michelle
because I was like, is this illegal?
Am I allowed to put my
arm around Michelle Obama?
Like, the Secret Service
is just gonna like,
jump out of the roof and
like, put your hands up!
So I was like--
- I think you chose wisely.
I would've been nervous, too.
- So it's just awkwardly standing,
you know, 14-year-old
Marcus, just like (whines).
- Oh my gosh!